hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play amnesia custom story
abduction alright gonna read a letter I
finally got it I've opened the portal to
another realm even Alexander with
everything evany nd okay
there is the same time period and people
as Alexander mercury and bromine blood
of the twisted blood must be extracted
first - then mercury must be added then
placed on a burner to heat it adding the
bromine okay very powerful gas perhaps
I'm unworthy yeah you are Oh what was
that what was that huh I gotta back off
don't even try it I'll bring it up who
was that who was that
come on killer Oh bring it ah I got a
chair I got a chair I'm just warning you
warning you warning you warning you
buddy got fair warning good for warning
don't do it don't do it
yeah yeah oh yeah
Oh tough haha no no no ha dictature take
the chair take it take it take it take
it
oh why didn't I hide in the closet huh
those dumb those dumb hey buddy he with
me are gonna hang around here for a
while while that thing stares at us
unnerving me it's almost like you can
see into our soul hello monster no no
what are you doing what are you doing oh
[ __ ] oh oh no oh oh God don't come in
here don't come in don't go oh oh I'm
running past you I'm running past you ah
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] off [ __ ] ah
[ __ ] off
I got a chair oh don't even try don't
even try no gonna give you up [ __ ] Oh
boom oh yeah right in your face give me
hot stuck
ha ha ah oh
gimme I know nothin empty room ah [ __ ]
up um ok ok did I win
wait another place now take it away from
him please please
ok ha
what the [ __ ] Oh what what no no no no
it's gonna kill me it's gonna kill me
it's gonna kill me is gonna do it ah oh
oh okay okay run run run run run run run
I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay
they're only right behind me they're
only right by me I'm only minutes away
from death I'm only minutes seconds
seconds away from death ah let me out
here with the door give me giving you no
okay oh yeah oh yeah oh I'll kick their
ass kick their ass from here to Tuesday
for your reference Saturday when I'm
recording this oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
huh okay all right did I win did I get
it all please don't make me go back in
there I get it okay the key East Wing
West East I'm gonna guess it's this way
wait I don't know that my cardinal
directions in here I can't even see the
Sun well whatever else try this one cuz
it's closed Oh
okay oh this is the West Wing I never
really watched that show okay why would
the key for the East Wing be over in the
West area this makes no sense at all no
sense at all
oh man that's freaky I thought I thought
for sure it was just another situation
where he was just gonna kill me and I
had no chance but I got away cuz I am so
skilled
so amazingly badass all right
oh this looks dark not as dark as the
other one though Ellen was mysteriously
darker hey is this my bedroom looks like
it okay nope hello oh you again
oh you didn't help me at all last time
oh and he's your friend
nobody smash all right here Oh chests
give me oil tinderbox
BAM okay no no no complete waste of my
time thank you so much for that anything
in here Oh another new dad boy he was a
clear tile he had to be killed I will
let nothing stand in my way
so many years have passed since I held
you my love but I promise
soon I will be with you once again don't
ask me what accent that was okay no
servants making regular patrols it is
only a matter of time even if I die by
his hand I don't know who he's talking
about
never met him in person
oh isn't now he's talking about me he
beat him once perhaps second time
um I don't know I don't know I don't
know who knows who knows always making
sure to close the doors behind me like
it seems like every single time I walk
into a room there's gonna be a monsters
Bonnie right behind me even my chairs
aren't helping me out here ten the box
oh these gonna be empty again probably
yep ah nothing nada not a damn thing all
right
wasting my time Lou hey anybody
tinderbox oh yeah finally this one come
on open all right
who's out there this is a big room
there's gonna be useful for running away
from people in ha right now right now
it's being used right now oh [ __ ] right
off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off don't even try it
don't don't even try man don't I'm
warning you I'm cornered I'm like a wild
animal
aah oh I can see it oh it's so ugly
oh okay it's walking away yeah oh man
yeah get out of here get out of here
you're so ugly wonder you don't have any
friends wonder your mother says such bad
things about you and how do I know what
your mother says oh you you don't even
want to know cuz if you're that ugly the
I don't even want to know
alright tinderbox drawers empty empty
okay
a key key where's the key I've been in
every room there's no key there is no
key buddy
ya see your zhabin in all these rooms do
I miss something there was no key here
there's no key there I've looked near
and far
nope nope I'm there not in the chest not
in the doodad ah how could there be a
key
find the painting uh oh yeah yep yep
ha ha ha ha ha no no no no no in the
closet in closet yep
yeah you can't get this oh what's that
oh you don't look so bad that I can see
you huh what what was that you want your
mama all right oh oh no no no no no no
no you saw nothing
you saw nothing you saw nothing nothing
repeat you saw nothing you know if I
were a monster the closets would be the
first place I'd check
get out of here you so ugly oh oh you so
ugly
maybe that's all he wants he just wants
a hug oh that reminded me I never got my
hug Emma Belle Swanson I'm sorry for
murdering you by dropping a giant box on
your head crushing it guys I really miss
my hug
go get out of here man no one likes you
are you gone did you leave did you leave
are you still there oh I don't get out
of here man what is it with this game
and those monsters patrolling in the
same room for about 15 minutes
stupid stupid ah just bad manners okay I
think he's gone
not 100% okay yeah he's gone oh right
gah
the nerve okay
goes in behind me okay um well this
looks like it was worth it another
painting off the wall yep thought so
chair boom oh so strong look at me
oh look at me alright um yeah I'm at a
cutter here thank you guys so much for
watching and I will see you guys in the
next part
bye bye